[Musique]
venu sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire deux ans après l'apparition
du comique 19 en chine l'europe en dépit
de son taux de vaccination se retrouve à
nouveau centre de la pandémie
particulièrement l'autriche qui vient de
re confiné sa population et l'allemagne
où le ministre de la santé a carrément
déclaré aujourd'hui que d'ici la fin de
l'hiver tous les allemands seront je le
cite vacciner geri mort alors la france
doit-elle elle aussi s'attendre au pire
s'agit-il d'une cinquième vague plus
violente encore que les précédentes les
non vaccinés en sont ils les seuls
responsables
faudra-t-il aussi vacciner les enfants
peut-on tout misé sur le vaccin alors
qu'ils n'empêchent pas de rattraper le
virus ni de le transmettre et que la
majorité des patients hospitalisés
aujourd'hui sont vaccinés
quid des traitements et d'autres mesures
de salubrité publique comme l'aération
des lieux clos donc presque personne ne
parle pour en débattre nous avons invité
antoine flahault épidémiologiste
professeur de santé publique directeur
de l'institut de santé globale de
l'université de genève vous êtes
l'auteur de qu'ovide le bal masqué aux
éditions dunod antoine flahault au
moment de la première vague vous êtes le
premier la première blouse blanche j'ai
envie de dire que j'ai interrogés dans
cette émission c'était donc il ya un
certain temps est-ce qu'on est d'après
vous au pied de la cinquième vague
la notion de wingles n'est pas une
notion
d'épidémiologie très classique vous ne
trouvez pas de définition d'une vague
dans un livre de l'épidémiologie
classique on peut dire que les vagues
c'est une terminologie de marins il ya
des vagues de houle et puis à des vagues
déferlantes
ce que l'on peut dire c'est que il y a
eu une vague déferlante
meurtrière très très forte
dans l'europe de l'est l'europe centrale
on peut dire aussi que des vagues de
houle très puissante
s'invite en europe de l'ouest et
commence à déferler c'est à dire
commence à causer une mortalité et des
hospitalisations assez importante pour
l'instant nous connaissons nous voyons
ces vagues à l'horizon qui déferle et
nous connaissons je crois en france en
suisse en italie en espagne au portugal
mais aussi d'ailleurs en finlande et en
suède
peut-être les quelques derniers moments
de répit d'une houle qui ne déferle pas
encore c'est à dire que la mortalité les
hospitalisations ne sont pas un niveau
qui pourrait définir ce que j'appelle
moi les vagues déferlantes jean michel
claverie vous vous êtes virologues
professeurs et praticiens hospitaliers
émérite de l'université d'aix marseille
co fondateur du laboratoire information
génomique et structurale
même question cinquième vague ou pas
cinquième bague
mais j'aurais du mal à contredire le
professeur qui est vraiment un
spécialiste épidémiologistes de ces
choses mais disons que on voit surtout
pour l'instant en france et dans un
certain nombre de pays bien vacciné une
espèce de dramatisation qui n'est pour
l'instant pas justifiée par les chiffres
comme l'on dit d'ailleurs beaucoup de
gens je visais un texte laurent toubiana
qui appartient à l'institut de recherche
sur la valorisation de données de santé
qu'elle a chercheur à l'inserm sérieux
qui disait qu'il ne comprenait pas qu'on
utilise systématiquement le mot
incidence pour simplement décrire des
gens qui ont une et sert positive et
donc seulement peut-être 20 à 10% seront
symptomatique et dont seulement 1 10%
éventuellement ont des grosses des
graves ennuis et termineront à l'hôpital
dont effectivement nous avons un nombre
important de gens qui sont positifs avec
ce virus que virus continue de circuler
on sait qu'il va d'ailleurs tu veux de
circuler pour toujours puisqu'il n'est
pas le dignité à l'espèce humaine
malheureusement on n'a pas pouvoir
l'éradiquer mais disons que sur le plan
de la santé publique
je ne pense pas qu'il faut s'alarmer
trop rapidement de cette 5e balle alors
comment expliquez vous tous les 2 qu'en
dépit de ces taux de vaccination
l'europe soit à nouveau le centre de la
pandémie anton flahaut
alors
clairement
le vaccin ne permet pas de faire barrage
aux transmissions
vous avez le vaccin avait été
testé lors des essais cliniques et avait
montré une efficacité sur la
transmission pour le variant qu'était le
variant originel devone
qui était de l'ordre de 70% aujourd'hui
clairement on n'est pas à 70 % parce que
sinon avec le taux de vaccination que
nous avons
que les hollandais ont aux pays-bas ou
même d'ailleurs les autrichiens ou les
allemands on serait très proche d'une
forme d'immunité collective qui
bloquerait toute nouvelle vague c'est
pas le cas donc je crois qu'il faut
reconnaître que le vaccin n'arrive pas à
bloquer l'arrivée de cette vague ce que
l'on voit aussi c'est que le vaccin
permet chez les gens vaccinés de
diminuer considérablement la morbidité
sévère et la mortalité c'est à dire que
les gens
ne font pas des formes sévères qui les
conduisent à l'hôpital les gens décèdent
en tout cas dans une proportion beaucoup
bien moindre la l'efficacité était dans
les essais cliniques de 80 ou 90% je
dirais qu'il semble au vu des résultats
des chiffres que l'on peut voir dans les
différents pays qui semble que ce soit à
peu près le même même efficacité sur ses
formes graves jean michel claverie
alors la même chose j'ai même été très
étonné donc on a en gros une
cinquantaine de deux desserts
jour dans les hôpitaux dieu sait qu'ils
sont bien sûr dès qu'il est un malade
est positif aucun vide qui sont
attribués au col vide alors que
forcément cette personne n'est pas morte
du col vide mais en général de bien
d'autres choses parce qu'encore une fois
ce sont des gens très âgés qui sont là
même la plupart touchés par ces formes
graves mais je regardais justement sur
sur santé publique franc je pense que eh
bien depuis fin octobre
2021 on a une très forte baisse de très
amusante c'est la mortalité on est fin
octobre depuis fin octobre d'une baisse
très importante de la mortalité vous
engage à aller consulter le site et on
est tombé à 1500 morts par jour alors
que normalement à cette époque de
l'année on en compte environ 1800
1730 en 2019 et on a vu un vrai pic de
mortalité due aux convives de 2300 2020
donc actuellement si on regarde les
chiffres on est dans une partie de la
coupe qui a une oeuvre très franchement
une perte là les têtes et journalière
donc il y avait qui montre ce point de
vue là ça ne justifie fabre est mort là
l'ère actuelle dont on nous dont on nous
fait pas si on est dans une période de
sous mortalité comment expliquerait ton
parce qu'on porte le masque justement et
qu'on se transmet moins de maladies jean
michel claverie oui je pense que c'est
probablement effectivement le fait qu'on
a plus quand même une vie sociale
parfaitement normal les gens sortent moi
les gens se protègent plus effectivement
les mesures barrières sur des mesures
importantes quand on ne sont bien sûr
appliquées de manière intelligente c'est
à dire pas bien sûr quand on est tout
seul sur une plage comme ça a été fait à
certaines époques on était verbalisé
consoeur fesses en masse ou auto se
balader en forêt mais effectivement dans
les cantons et très confiné quand on est
encore gré quand on est en dedans le
métro avoir le match bien sûr on pêche
toute transmission non seulement d'une
copine à tout un peu la transmission
décors vides mais également de toutes
les maladies infectieuses respiratoires
habituels qu'on a cependant livré en
temps de faro oui j'ajouterai à ses
explications
ce qu'on appelle un effet de moisson
c'est à dire que il y a eu une
surmortalité l'année dernière qui a
fauché des personnes âgées très âgées
qui serait si je puis dire probablement
décédés cette année ou un peu plus tard
parce que c'était des personnes qui
avaient des comorbidités importante et
qui n'avaient pas une espérance de vie
très très longue et ces personnes
manquent à au décès au registre du décès
de cette année puisqu'elle sont décédés
l'année dernière c'est ce que j'appelle
l'effet de deux mois sont donc si je
vous comprends bien le vaccin n empêche
pas d'attraper le virus le vaccin
n'empêche pas de transmettre le virus en
revanche ils empêchent de développer des
formes graves mais encore il est fiable
à 90% pas à 100%
oui il faut aussi nuancé le vaccin
n'empêche pas d'attraper le virus je
pense que le vaccin l'empêchent il
réduit les tranches des transmissions
mais pas de 70% est ce que cette 30%
est-ce que c'est 50 % je ne sais pas
mais c'est sans doute pas non plus 0%
c'est pas c'est pas noir ou blanc et
comme vous le dites tout à fait c'est
très important de le dire 80 ou 90% de
réduction de mortalité en tout cas de
réduction de formes graves grâce au
vaccin c'est très appréciable c'est un
très bon vaccin mais c'est pas 100%
c'est tout à fait exact mais alors si le
vaccin n'empêche pas d'attraper le virus
ni de le transmettre qui l'empêchent
quand même de développer des formes
graves
pourquoi vacciner les enfants enfin
pourquoi faudrait-il vacciner les
enfants jean michel claverie
c'est pas moi qu'il faut le demander
parce que je milite depuis pas dans
quelques mois contre totalement cette
vaccination en pensant qu'elle est
inutile et même d'ailleurs
contre-productive je ne comprends pas
par exemple quand des dans des classes
de maternelle ou dans des classes
d'enfants très jeunes se déclarent un
cas de co vide positive donc en général
l'enfant est né à peine malades où il a
le nez qui coule on ferme la classe mon
avis ce qu'il faudrait faire ses marques
et aux gardes et la classe laisser les
enfants faire leur immunité naturelle
avec cette maladie extrêmement bening et
ça rajouterait à la population française
tant qu'une fraction de jeunes qui
seraient immunisés et qui serait usé
langue de molière pas non plus efficace
que par le vaccin parce que plus au long
de plus longue durée est plus résistante
aux variations parce qu'elle est dirigée
contre un total et du livre totalité des
virus et pas seulement une seule
protéines vaccinales je pense que c'est
vraiment une erreur importante que de ne
pas laisser les enfants faire leur copie
en qu'il dans leurs points et ne pas les
embêter avec des vaccins dont on ne sait
pas encore et jeunes insiste là-dessus
et légitimant la dangerosité parce que
les quelques articles qui ont été
publiés sur ce domaine sont des articles
qui sont on peut le dire essentiellement
bâclé qui ont été très fait très
rapidement qui porte sur quelques
milliers au maximum d'enfants et je le
papier qui fait principe qui a été
publié dans un des plus grands journaux
médical a suivi les enfants en moyenne
57 jours après la deuxième dose je
n'estime pas que ça soit un recul
suffisant pour estimer que ces vaccins
ne sont pas dangereux pour les enfants
qui eux pour des maladies extrêmement
bénigne en pas de flaran
oui je m'inscris évidemment pas dans ce
type de discours discours qu'on avait
déjà entendu pour le vaccin contre la
varicelle qu'on avait même entendu pour
le vaccin contre la rougeole qu'on a
parfois entendu pour le vaccin contre le
papillomavirus
tous ces vaccins
on vraiment changer le paysage dans le
domaine de l'épidémiologie des maladies
infantiles je pense que
lakovic 19 est une sale maladie le virus
est un virus extrêmement retors
il a tué aux états unis 700 enfants dont
l'un tiers n'avait aucune comorbidités
des petits enfants je pense que le coc
vide donne des copies de long qui sont
très invalidants qui sont handicapant
pour les enfants pour leur scolarité
les
épidémiologistes
australienne disait ce matin sur twitter
qu'elle
redoutait une deuxième pandémie après
cette pandémie de kobe de 19 qui serait
la pandémie de kovy de nom c'est à dire
que on s'attend à avoir un grand nombre
pas simplement chez les enfants mais
aussi chez les enfants de d'enfants qui
ont fait des copies très banal de forme
très banale mais qui ont pu développer
ses formes longue qui les empêche de
retourner à l'école qui les handicapent
profondément donc je trouve que par
ailleurs il se trouve que ce vaccin est
une extraordinaire sécurité on a deux
millions huit cent mille enfants qui ont
été de 5 à 11 ans qui ont été vaccinés
aux états unis avec tous les projecteurs
braqués sur cette campagne de
vaccination nord américaine avec de très
bons outils épidémiologique de vaccinaux
vigilance qui n'a rien montré c'est à
dire rien montré de ce qu'on ne savait
pas les enfants ont une un excellent
système immunitaire donc ils développent
une très grande immunité grâce à la
vaccination et ils font très peu
d'effets indésirables ils font des bio
car dit qu'ils sont des atteintes du
coeur qui sont quelque chose à prendre
en considération
mais ils en font à un niveau bien
moindre de fréquences que s'ils font un
co vide parce qu'il ya des mieux car dit
beaucoup plus graves liés au vide par
ailleurs il ya aucun mort ou qu'une
mortalité qui n'a été recensé
aujourd'hui avec tout le recul que l'on
a sur l'expérience noire américaine deux
millions huit cent mille enfants
vaccinés aucune mortalité
les quelques myocardite qui ont eu lieu
était très rare et ont tout régressé
donc voilà je pense que c'est dommage de
ne pas faire profiter aux enfants deux
d'un vaccin très sûr et très efficace
chez eux en plus si grâce à cela ça peut
contribuer à minimiser un peu parce
qu'ils ont une très bonne immunité ça
marchera mieux que chez l'adulte encore
si ça peut minimiser la transmission qui
fera moins de cas dans les écoles - des
clus de classes fermées socialement ça
jouera un rôle collectif indéniable dont
on se réjouira tous les jours donc vois
moi je ne comprends pas trop les
réticences je les entends parce que
c'est vrai que les nouveaux vaccins on a
envie d'avoir une expérience d'habitude
on a dû on met du temps à voir d'abord
cette expérience parce que ça n'arrive
pas d'avoir deux millions huit cent
mille personnes vaccinées en quelques
mois et est donc c'est l'expérience du
coc vide nous nous raccourci
profondément les délais habituels et en
raison de cela je pense qu'il n'y a pas
de d'inquiétude à avoir et en revanche
il ya beaucoup d'inquiétudes à avoir le
coc vide j'aimerais pas que mes petits
enfants attrapent locaux vides en ce
moment dans michel claverie n'est pas
convaincu
pas du tout je veux je pense vraiment
qu'il n'y a pour l'instant
rigoureusement aucune étude sérieuse qui
permettent de conclure à l'innocuité de
ces vaccins sur une longue période de
temps là le kobe de long est
actuellement très remis en cause par
quelques études extrêmement sérieuse
dans des grands journaux encore une fois
bon on sait plus trop qu'il faut croire
en se disant que ça la plupart du temps
on a l'impression que le kobe de long et
une origine plutôt psychosomatiques que
réelle le piano ce type de kobe de long
est extrêmement vague extrêmement
difficile à poser on le pose quand ça
arrange le pose pas quand ça n'arrange
pas et je veux vraiment dire aussi que
il faut pas penser
cela les statistiques de qui répertorie
les effets indésirables graves des
vaccins y compris les décès sont sont
fiables elles sont
thouars mans totalement sous-estimé
jusqu'à probablement 1% seulement des
cas des cas sont sous-estimés des
quelqu'un meurt et est positif du col
vide eh bien il est classé comme mort du
co vide et pour arriver à faire admettre
que quelqu'un qui meurt quinze jours
après sa deuxième injection est mort à
cause du vaccin c'est pratiquement
impossible avec les réglementations
actuelles on trouve toujours le dire est
une excuse au vaccin et ce n'est
vraiment pas un risque que je suis
disposé à prendre étant donné que alors
qu'on avait soi-disant beaucoup de recul
on se rend compte que ce vaccin qui
avait beaucoup de recul une les plus
efficaces après six mois on aura
peut-être du mal à percevoir avant et en
plus que énormément d'effets secondaires
ou été totalement nouveau c'est mieux
car dit c'est thrombose profonde c'est
péricardite et à l'inflammation
vasculaires et une autre à chinon pas
été prédite par les essais cliniques
encore une fois un peu bâclé je pense
que il est bien trop tôt pour compléter
les enfants avec ce vaccin étant donné
qu'ils font des maladies extrêmement
minime et ça je maintiens parce qu'il
n'y a pas véritablement une littérature
y décrit n'oubliez pas qu'on va campus
aux états unis la plupart des enfants
ont commandité importante c'est que la
plupart des enfants états unis sont
obèses
antoine flahault
non je crois que là les registres de
vaccinaux vigilance ne fonctionne pas
comme le disent comme le dit monsieur
claverie l'imputation c'est à dire de
savoir mettre la relation de cause à
effet entre un décès est un vaccin est
en effet un exercice qui est difficile
et parfois on peut d experts peuvent
être en désaccord sur l'imputation
certains disent que l'imputation et
causale qui a une relation de cause à
effet qui est probable et d'autres
disent qu'elle est improbable et ça il
peut y avoir des discussions mais c'est
pas comme ça que ça fonctionne en
réalité parce que tous les décès
survenant après vaccination
s'il y en a eh bien ils sont tous
répertoriés en dehors de toute
imputation donc on peut au moins savoir
s'il ya eu des décès
post vaccinaux ne parlons même pas de la
cause la relation de cause à effet qui
est un jugement qui est une évaluation
mais simplement y at-il eu des décès
banon il y en a pas eu il y en a pas il
n'y a pas eu de décès post vaccinaux je
parle pas des décès après s'il y avait
eu des desserts ou se seraient tous
probablement pencher sur la cause et
peut-être qu'on n'aurait pas été
d'accord mais je ne parle pas ici d'un
d'un jugement de valeur par ailleurs ce
que je me dis monsieur claverie est
exact sur le long qu'ovide cdc coville
dont ces des pathologies qui sont
complexes qui sont difficiles alors un
peu trop rapidement ou les classes comme
psychosomatique vous savez il ya
beaucoup de domaines vous savez le
maladie de parkinson étaient considérés
comme psychosomatiques jusqu'à ce qu'on
s'aperçoive que c'était une vraie
maladie neurologique il ya beaucoup de
pathologies qu'on croyait
psychosomatiques sais pas si vous savez
mais l'ulcère de l'estomac c'est dû à
une bactérie b autrefois on disait assez
des gens qui sont nerveux qui sont voilà
donc malheureusement les patients
souffrent énormément de cette sorte de
mépris de la part de la communauté
médicale qui n'aime pas ne pas bien
comprendre pas bien classés ne pas bien
m un diagnostic sur une maladie et qui
la classe rapidement comme
psychosomatiques ce qui veut dire c'est
dans votre tête que ça se passe en fait
probablement les choses sont plus
compliquées il y ait des gens qui soient
plus fragile psychologiquement et qui
développe d'ailleurs qui sait des formes
ou des complications dues au virus du
que vides qui a un euro tropisme
important il ya quand même beaucoup de
publications là dessus c'est pas
impossible que ça détériore leurs
fonctions mentales ça n'est pas
impossible mais qu'il y ait aussi des
gens qui perdent le goût et l'odorat ce
qu'ils sont des choses totalement
neurologique s'est pas dans la tête que
ça se passe c'est même sur des nerfs qui
cercle viennent du cerveau mais qui sont
des pertes de goût et de doha qui sont
des copies de et qui sont aussi
extrêmement handicapants chez l'adulte
mais aussi chez l'enfant qu'il y ait par
ailleurs des grandes asthénie très
prolongée chez des enfants qui était en
pleine forme avant qu'ils n'avaient
aucun signe de lassitude de dépression
c'est des choses qui doivent nous
préoccupe et je pense qu'on peut pas
balayer ça d'un revers de la main et
même s'il est possible qu'il ya beaucoup
de progrès qu'ils se fassent dans les
années à venir à mon avis c'est
suffisamment préoccupant pour justifier
que l'on fasse tout pour que les enfants
n'attrape pas ce que ville avançons on
va pas rester sur les enfants trop
longtemps le problème si cinquième vague
i lya ou peu importe le nom qu'on lui
donne ce sera fatalement aux urgences
que sa valise réglé on a toujours peur
de de l'engorgement des hôpitaux
alors est ce qui est ce qui vous semble
le mieux préparer les hôpitaux presse
qu'il commença ça fait deux ans que ça
dure maintenant jean michel claverie
alors justement j'écoutais de monsieur
jean michel contenta professeur à des
stylistes réanimateur à la pitié
salpêtrière
qui lui aussi
n'ayez je dirais l'appellation cinquième
vague en disant que en ce qui concerne
la pitié salpêtrière et alors qu'il est
chef du service valeur de réanimation il
ne voyait pas il nous il l'a dit il ya
deux jours je crois il ne voyait pas
d'affluence dans son service du haut
cohabitent donc là encore il faudrait
faire faire très attention
je pense pas que les instances
sanitaires officiers le gouvernement
joue parfaitement réglo dans cette
histoire est content à nous faire peur
avec des chiffres qui ne sont pas
forcément toujours avérée notamment
quand on parle de gens qui sont en en
soins critiques il faut bien voir que en
soins critiques ya trois ou quatre
niveaux différents et les gens qui sont
en soins continus ils sont dans leur lit
à qui on ne fait rien on leur prend
l'oxygène au regarde tu m'as bien il ya
des gens qui sont effectivement avec des
soins réel et il ya en fin de compte ce
que l'on connaît bien parce qu'on les
voit toujours à la télévision qui sont
une vraie animation avec intubation et
tout ça si tu doutes partie des gens qui
sont admis à l'hôpital et actuellement
ou une pca positive en france eh bien on
a alors deux pour cent des gens la
plupart les plus âgés y avait des
comorbidités qui vont aller à l'hôpital
et un demi pour cent le ces gens là vont
faire un séjour en soins critiques alors
ce que je ne comprends pas c'est que
maintenant la gravité d'une maladie
n'est plus estimé en fonction de sa
véritable natalité au nom la variole 50%
de gens qui attrapent la variole en
meurent mais maintenant elle est classée
par rapport au nombre de lits
hospitaliers qu elle sature alors vu
qu'on arrête pas diminuer le nombre de
lits en réanimation et de soins
critiques en france on va bientôt
arriver à avoir des alertes sanitaires
très graves pour des gastro entérites
parce que il y en aura de moins en moins
de lits lits de réanimation d'un cas je
pense vraiment que on a un vrai problème
pour nos statistiques a plus une maladie
grave une maladie qui attaque on sature
les hôpitaux qui sont notoirement sous
dotées réponse dans le tonneau minutes
parce qu'après on fait une pause antoine
aujourd'hui il ya 45 décès par jour en
france due à la copie de 19 à comparer à
la dernière vague la vague de cet été
avait monté la mortalité à peu près 110
112 au moment du pic mais si l'on
regarde à incidence égal vous savez il
ya un décalage entre
les contaminations puis les
hospitalisations puis plus tard encore
les décès eh bien il n'y avait pas
beaucoup plus de décès au début de la
quatrième vague jeu pour rappel pour
rappel un la quatrième vague par exemple
dans la région de monsieur claverie ça a
été la plus forte vague jamais
enregistré de toute la pandémie en
matière de contamination
je parle bien de la vague qui a eu lieu
cet été donc ce n'était pas une petite
vague en corse ce n'était pas une petite
vague en nouvelles aquitaine pour
prendre un autre exemple en occitanie
c'était une petite vague en revanche ce
que j'appelle des vagues de houle en
bretagne par exemple où il n'y a pas eu
beaucoup de déferlement pas eu beaucoup
de décès mais aujourd'hui ce que je veux
dire c'est qu'on est à peu près au même
niveau de mortalité que ce qu'on
s'attendait à avoir dans une période où
on avait un tout petit peu moins
vacciner c'était au coeur de l'été et
donc on peut être inquiet lorsque l'on
voit le développement qui n'a aucune
raison de ne pas se produire qui se
produit en ce moment aux pays bas ou en
allemagne les pays-bas ont le même
niveau de vaccination que le nôtre
l'allemagne est à 230 décès par jour
juste pour mémoire 90 décès par jour en
france c'est la cause de mortalité qui
tue le plus c'est l'infarctus du
myocarde
donc quand on est à 45 on est à la
moitié ça va on a encore un peu de marge
mais vous voyez qu'on n'est déjà plus
dans des petites maladies qui tuerait
peut on est dans des maladies qui
commence à tuer beaucoup et bien en
allemagne déjà aujourd'hui en grande
bretagne aussi aux pays bas la nouvelle
vague tu es au devient la première cause
de mortalité dans leur pays ont fait une
pause et on reprend ce débat juste après
[Musique]
alors de la coop 26 et d'un g20
particulièrement tourné sur le climat
comment répondre à nos besoins
énergétiques tout en prenant en compte
les défis environnementaux comme
d'habitude si vous voulez les coptes
sont des endroits où on fixe la date de
la prochaine coop les émissions de co2
n'ont jamais autant augmenté au niveau
mondial que depuis qu'on est celle de
fait abaissé aujourd'hui n'a un espèce
de mots d'ordre qui est de fermer les
usines nucléaires mais sans penser à
comment on les remplace si demain on a
tous des voitures électriques on n'a pas
de on n'a plus de voiture qui roule au
pétrole il va falloir qu'il y ait
beaucoup d'électricité produite et c'est
pas avec avec l'éolien pas d'énergie
parfaite on a été le premier importateur
mondial de gaz de schiste par contre
qu'est ce qu'on fait en france interdit
[Musique]
le continent compte bien sûr quelques
femmes présidentes à son actif mais
souvent un titre symbolique à fiat et
ben bella ming êtes une femme politique
est ce que votre parcours a été semé
d'embûches sur les six que voilà vous
êtes là pour l
avoir les idées quand on regarde les
chiffres sur 255 députés n'ont que vingt
neuf ans qui sont les femmes ferait
mieux que les hommes dans le domaine de
l'éveil démocratique lorsque les femmes
sont de plus en plus prises en compte
dans l'échiquier politique
ça traduit généralement un d'éveil des
consciences un éveil politique bénéficie
à la population d'une manière générale
l'évolution des femmes en politique ça
ne doit pas être qu'une idée ça va elle
aussi un engagement que le président
[Musique]
on reprend notre débat sur cette
nouvelle vague de covin 19 avec
l'épidémiologiste antoine flahault et le
virologue jean michel claverie là
les non vaccinés sont ils aujourd'hui
les principaux responsables
de cette vague de co vide alors plus
particulièrement forte dans des pays
comme l'allemagne l'autriche ou les pays
bas qu'en france mais néanmoins la
france pourrait être la prochaine sur la
liste
les non vaccinés en sont-ils les
principaux responsables
et dans ce cas faut-il les confiner
comme l'autriche s'apprêtaient à le
faire avant de confirmer finalement tout
le monde s'en dit que cette action les
vacciner comme les non vaccinés antoine
flahault
alors personnellement moi j'aime pas
trop cette
recherche de bouc émissaire je pense que
le grand danger dans une pandémie comme
celle ci c'est que
les débats soient clivant soit violent
que les gens se sentent exclus
discriminés et tout ce qui vise à
diviser la société doit être très
durement combattu c'est à dire que
chercher des boucs émissaires
aujourd'hui parmi les non vaccinés
sachant que les vaccinés transmettent on
l'a dit au début de virus certes
peut-être un peu moins que les non
vaccinés mais si c'est 30 % d'efficacité
comme on l'a dit sur la transmission
puisqu'on a des hypothèses de ce genre
de prétendre que les non vaccinés
seraient les responsables me paraît être
violent dangereux contre-productif donc
je suis pas du tout convaincu pour ma
part que ce soit le cas je pense que ça
n'a pas d'intérêt de rechercher ce genre
de choses ce qui est on voit la ville à
la vague elle se développe extrêmement
fortement en europe de l'est ce alors
les non-vaccinés payer un tribut très
lourds en europe de l'est vis-à-vis de
cette vague
mais la vague elle est aussi forte aux
pays bas qui est extrêmement vacciner
comme nous finalement on a vu aussi à
singapour une vague très importantes y
avait 80 % de l'accident néanmoins à
antoine flahault quand vous dites il
faut combattre tout ce qu'ils nous
disent emi nous divise est-ce que vous
incluez le past and iter est ce qu'il se
passe a dit r ça nous divise et ceux qui
ne nions pas droit s'estiment
discriminés
oui alors le pass sanitaires vous savez
moi je suis épidémiologistes chacun a
son rôle mon rôle à moi c'est de dire
plus les gens sont vaccinés mieux c'est
pour cela
certains états ont recours à la
vaccination obligatoire d'autres au pass
sanitaires il ya des états aux états
unis parce que c'est plus leur culture
ils ont eu recours à des incitations
financières on a payé les gens même
d'ailleurs en grèce on a donné 100 euros
pour les gens qui voulaient bien se
faire vacciner moi ça m'est égal je suis
pas c'est pas mon rôle de décider cela
que des politiques disent en france on
va plutôt prendre le pass tanit
rcc le rôle des politiques ce que je dis
c'est quand on dit c'est l'euro c'est la
faute des non vaccinés là on est plus
dans le domaine du politique on est dans
le domaine de l'anathème on est vraiment
dans un domaine qui est un domaine où on
va chercher des boucs émissaires comme
dans toutes les pandémies et je pense
que c'est contreproductif par michel
claverie mais je suis content de
retomber d'accord avec antoine flahault
qui est un mauvais sort que je respecte
énormément
effectivement il faudrait faire un petit
calcul mathématique mais je vous
rappelle qu'en france notamment les non
vaccinés sont maintenant une minorité
puisque on n'arrête pas de se vanter de
notre grand succès vaccinale donc on va
dire 10% de la population ne seraient
pas vaccinés donc pour qu'il soit
vraiment les pelé qui soit vraiment les
les propagateurs principaux il faudrait
que lors la préparation lors la
transmission du virus par les vaccinés
soit beaucoup plus importante qu'elle
est allée vacciner je ne pense pas que
les données que nous quittons nous
disposons vont dans ce sens donc il
faudrait que les entraîneurs vaccinées
soit neuf fois plus transmetteur par
exemple que les vacciner ce qui n'est
pas le cas par contre effectivement vous
avez parfaitement raison le pass
sanitaire dans cette configuration
maintenant qu'on a enfin compris que
l'airé vaccinées étaient des gens en
effet aussi dangereux entre guillemets
que les non vaccinés n'a plus aucune
justification scientifique et ça me mène
à un autre poids qui beaucoup depuis
tout le début de cette pandémie c'est
que le politique a pris énormément de
décision sous couvert et en demandant en
fin de compte l'approbation de certains
scientifiques alors qu' il n'y avait
absolument rien de scientifique dans ses
décisions et ça continue et ça a
contribué à affaiblir énormément le rôle
de la science dans la société parce que
maintenant on a l'impression que les
scientifiques il disait un petit peu ce
qui leur passe par la tête est ce que le
gouvernement peut bien leur faire dire
et ça c'est vraiment très important et
c'est très grave parce que ça a vraiment
miner la confiance de la population
envers la vie scientifique parce que
qu'un évidemment quand on demande à des
scientifiques de justifier le port du
masque à l'extérieur en pleine forêt où
qu'au début on disait que le masque
était dangereux qui était il était
inutile et maintenant on ne pense qu'aux
masques et puis quand on a commencé à
dire que et bien le pass annie terne
dans la jungle n'a aucune incidence pour
aller au restaurant ou n'importe quoi
que je fasse un mensonge permanent à
chaque fois conforté par un certain
nombre de scientifiques
je pense qu'on fait très très mal à la
société et amène maintenant ces
réactions extrêmement violente que l'on
voit émerger partout en europe et en
guadeloupe
antoine flahault le gouvernement
français vient de décider de rendre
obligatoire le masque pour les skieurs
dès l'âge de 2 11 ans je crois sur les
les remontées mécaniques alors y compris
les téléskis et les télésièges qui sont
en extérieur est ce que ça vous papa ne
paraît pas absurde en direct ils n'ont
pas encore compris ce qu'eux mais
semble-t-il les scientifiques soit à peu
près tous d'accord aujourd'hui pour des
cons ne se contaminent quasiment jamais
en extérieur on se contaminent en
extrait un intérieur dans les lieux clos
d'ailleurs vous assistez vous même on va
en parler dans un instant sur l'aération
des lieux clos parce que ça personne ne
le lit on préfère dire porter un masque
sur les pistes de ski ce qui semble
absurde oui je partage totalement votre
avis c'est absurde c'est totalement
absurde que dans les oeufs les
télécabines les téléphériques ont autant
les que peut-être même qu'ils sont un
semi ouverte on puisse demander de le
port du masque oui sur un téléski c'est
totalement absurde jean michel claverie
même j'imagine même même réponse
absolument mais j'irai j'irai même plus
loin quand on voyait que on était pas
obligé de porter d'avoir un pass
sanitaires pour prendre le rer mais
qu'ils en font actuellement pour prendre
le tgv on peut se demander quels sont
les scientifiques qui ont pu avaliser
une telle décision je vous rappelle
l'histoire du couvre feu je vous
donnerais ou de l'effet de me trouver
une étude scientifique qui montre qu'un
couvre-feu à 18h empêcher le code il est
plus efficace qu'un conte bref pas 19
heures ou à 20 heures et pourtant on a
trouvé des gens capables de justifier ce
genre de choses sous couvert
scientifique ce que je trouve vraiment
absolument déplorable je pense que là
des scientifiques se sont se sont mis au
service de politiques qui n'étaient
absolument pas guidée par des
connaissances scientifiques avérées
antoine flahault vous assistez vous au
contraire
sur l'aération des lieux clos vous
n'êtes pas toujours entendus est ce que
ça veut dire qu'on se continue de
sous-estimer en france et pas seulement
en france et pas seulement chez les
politiques d'ailleurs peut être aussi
chez les scientifiques on continue de
sous-estimer la transmission par les
aérosols et continue de croire qu'on se
contaminent en touchant un objet
qu'aurait touché quelqu'un qui avait le
co lead je me souviens au début de la
pandémie quand on nettoyait nos courses
on continue de croire qu'en se transmet
le virus en ce postillonnant soit dans
la bouche soit dans les yeux et on
continue d'ignorer qu'on se transmet par
micro gouttelettes qui reste d'un qui
reste dans une pièce quand on n'ouvre
pas les fenêtres
ah ben c'est pas c'est pas
en train de faire ou qui va me répondre
visiblement à bengalore réponse de
jean-michel claverie notant qu' antoine
flahault nous nous rejoignent
un certain nombre de gens depuis très
très longtemps insiste énormément sur ce
sur ce problème j'ai moi même été un des
premiers militants à l'époque que le
masque était hors la loi à être avec des
gens de avec des collègues de strasbourg
à méditer pour le port du masque mais on
est en sciant de faire comprendre aux
gens que c'est bien évidemment pas un
masque que l'on porte le masque on a qu
il ya des trous bâtiment partout de
centimètre carré absolu martou qui va
vous protéger un virus qui est dans
l'air effectivement et qui fait sens
manomètres cent millième de millimètre
dans l'atmosphère le masque et des très
importants tels que quelqu'un se sent
malade et qu'il se plus il sent bien que
ça va pas bien et l'année qui coule lui
effectivement c'est comme quand on
empêcher avant après la guerre les gens
de postillonner par terre ou de cracher
par terre quand il avait la tuberculose
même principe quand on est malade on a
absolument un masque pour empêcher
effectivement de propager ce virus dans
l'atmosphère comment ce virus et des
vêtements et dans l'atmosphère c'est
évidemment pour le fait de porter un
masque avec des trous partout qui avons
protégé veux pas qu'ils soient antoine
flahault
oui je pense que vous avez vraiment tout
à fait
indiquée cette sorte de négligence
étonnante de la part de toute la
communauté scientifique mais aussi
politique vis-à-vis de ce problème des
aérosols c'est étonnant parce que
aujourd'hui les scientifiques sont tous
d'accord pour dire que le sar ce cos 2
de l'agent virales responsables de deux
lakovic 19 et transmis par voie aérosols
c'est à dire comme vous l'avez très bien
dit dans nos gouttelettes de respiration
qui peuvent s'accumuler planer comme ça
dans une pièce mal ventilée quand on est
à l'extérieur qu'on les voit ces
gouttelettes de respiration quand il
fait froid vous savez ce petit village
qui sort de deux narines il se dilue
dans l'atmosphère immédiatement et donc
il n'y a aucun cas rapportés sur les
plus de 200 millions de cas y'a aucun
cas rapportés dans la littérature de
contamination de ce genre en revanche
les contaminations sont rapportés
totalement c'est à dire sauf petite
anecdote totalement dans des lieux clos
mal ventilée souvent bondées et ses
lieux qu'il faut sécuriser en fait il ya
eu très peu de recherches bien contre
bien construite pour montrer
l'efficacité de la ventilation sur le
contre locaux vides alors que dans
d'autres agents infectieux qui se
transmettent aussi par aérosol par
exemple le bacille de la tuberculose
il ya beaucoup de travaux très
démonstratif en particulier je voudrais
signaler un travail que j'ai bien aimé
qui a été publié vous savez en décembre
2010 knox juste avant le démarrage de
cette pandémie par une équipe taïwanaise
il investiguer une épidémie de
tuberculose
dans une université de taïwan ils se
sont rendus compte que les locaux
étaient pas vétuste mais ils ont voulu
faire des mesures de co2 parce que c'est
très difficile de savoir dans un local
cil et bien ventilé ou pas et ils ont vu
des taux de concentration de co2 très
élevé 3200 parties par million c'est
très élevé pour vous dire dans la rue
c'est 400 on s'attend à avoir un minimum
de 400 mails à 3200 donc ils se sont dit
ça ça doit être un lieu propice aux
contaminations on va tout faire pour
faire baisser et donc ils ont mis une
bonne aération ils ont ouvert les
fenêtres aux étages dans les sous sols
ils ont mis des purificateurs d'air
breizh quand est tombée à moins de 1000
tpm il y avait 95 % de contamination en
moins et ils ont encore continuer au
dessous de 600 ppm on se rapproche
presque de la rue alors il ya zéro
contamination alors voilà on aimerait
des travaux comme ça pour que qu'ils
puissent appuyer les politiques
publiques mais en attendant si on veut
vraiment réduire la transmission mais
qui est contre la ventilation je vous
pose la question que l'on soit contre le
port du masque c'est dommage parce que
c'est très efficace mais ça gêne un peu
les gens qu'on soit contre les
confinements le télétravail 2 le jute ou
toutes les misères que l'on a pu subir
eh bien on peut le comprendre des leçons
liberticides vous parliez du pass
sanitaire c'est aussi un peu liberticide
on est tous d'accord avec cela mais la
ventilation qui est contre respirer un
air qui est un peu purifiée deuxièmement
est ce que ça coûte cher non les
capteurs de co2 ne coûte pas cher du
tout et les purificateurs d'air il ya
des très bons ingénieurs
nord-américain j'aimerais bien car né en
france qui se penche sur la question par
exemple mais qui ont fait circuler sur
youtube de façon virale des façons de
faire soi même avec quelques éléments
qu'on achète un ventilateur par ci un
bon filtre homologué par là une vraie un
vrai purificateurs d'air pour 50 dollars
donc ça ne coûte pas cher ça n'a pas
beaucoup d'empreinte carbone ça n'a pas
beaucoup de consommation énergétique on
devrait vraiment ce qu'ils s'équipent et
dans les salles fermées recevant du
public de ce type d'appareil est mesuré
le co2 jean michel claverie c'est quand
même aberrant quand on est dans paris on
prend un taxi
généralement il ya une ya comme les
autres taxis et américains il ya une une
plaque entre le chauffeur et le passager
sa date du début de la pandémie sa mars
maintenant le chauffeur à masquer le
passager à l'arrière à la masse qu il
suffirait de le redire à tous les deux
ouvrez votre fenêtre et il n'y a plus
aucun reste pourquoi ne leur dit on pas
si c'est à moi de répondre je pense que
malheureusement
c'est encore malheureusement à un moyen
de contrôler un petit peu les esprits le
port du masque est une mesure un peu
vexatoires dont on a pris l'habitude qui
équipe qui génère effectivement un
climat anxiogène dans la rue dans les
dents des bâtiments et en a vraiment du
mal à en sortir effectivement voir
quelqu'un qui se baladent dans un
couloir bien ventilé sans masque pas
plus faire peur aux gens de voir
quelqu'un qui se bat avec un masque dans
un couloir qui n'est pas ventilé le
problème c'est que on s'est habitué à
une espèce de politique de l'absurde et
qui continue et je pense qu'il est
important que les gouvernements
à la faveur des mouvements sociaux on
commence à voir éclore un peu partout se
ressaisissent et prennent un petit peu
la parole de vrais scientifiques qui
vont leur dire vraiment pas faire et non
pas se plier à des simples desiderata
solution politique ou même commerciaux
parce que encore une fois dans cette
folie de tout compte de tout confié
maintenant à pas d'heure essentiellement
se pose quand même vraiment des
problèmes de conflits d'intérêts je vous
rappelle par exemple kauffeisen nous
avait dit ce qui est fantastique avec
les d'axa et rennes c'est qu'on peut
changer de vaccins quand on veut en un
mois on peut faire un vaccin anti
variantes comme le delta pourquoi ce
n'est pas fait est ce que c'est parce
qu'il faut maintenant écluser les
millions de doses qui ont été acheté par
l'europe est ce que je ne comprends pas
il est clair que ce vaccin ne
fonctionnent plus très bien six mois
après son iphone inoculation pourquoi on
n'est pas en train de fabriquer un
vaccin
2.0 je vois contre le delta je vous la
question
antoine flahault vous avez la réponse
vous pensez qu'il est toujours aussi
efficace il comprit comprend le delta
non non je pense que il est moins
efficace sur la transmission qu'il était
dans les essais cliniques donc monsieur
que la vraie raison si on avait
peut-être un vaccin plus
précis plus performant contre la
transmission serait très content
aujourd'hui donc c'est vrai qu'on un
vaccin qui est heureusement et c'était
vrai que c'est cela qu'on lui demandait
en premier
très efficace contre les formes sévères
mais on aimerait bien aujourd'hui
disposer d'un vaccin qui puisse vous
faire rêver d'une immunité collective
c'est totalement impossible aujourd'hui
c'est une utopie d unités collectives et
et les traitements alors où en est on
avec les traitements antoine alors c'est
encore c'est une bonne question parce
que les traitements on peut probablement
pas leur reprocher aux pouvoirs publics
ils sont en train d'arriver donc la
semaine dernière encore l' agence
européenne du médicament était en train
d'homologuer deux nouveaux traitements
antiviraux dans les traitements il faut
distinguer trois traitements trois types
de traitement il ya les antiviraux qui
sont des petites pilules con on peut
installer pendant cinq jours au tout
début des symptômes et qui permettent de
ne pas avoir de formes graves dans un
grand nombre de cas donc ça peut être
très intéressant parce que grâce à ces
traitements on peut éviter d'aller à
l'hôpital par exemple donc l'utile leur
utilisation peut être très précieuse
pour éviter la saturation des hôpitaux
sans parler du bénéfice direct pour le
patient qui risquait de faire une forme
grave et puis à des anticorps
monoclonaux qui ont des propriétés
antivirales
c'est un peu compliqué comme jargon mais
c'est des médicaments qui se donne en
perfusion à l'hôpital mais avant qu'on
soit hospitalisé dans les tout premiers
jours de l'infection un peu comme les
antiviraux finalement mais simplement
ils sont un peu plus coûteux et ils sont
un peu plus compliquées administrés
puisqu'il faut une perfusion et non des
gélules qu'on a qu'on avale ils sont
aussi très efficace peut-être encore
plus pour éviter l'hospitalisation
salir les formes graves qui entraîne de
spécialisation en soins intensifs ou
éventuellement le décès et puis après il
ya d'autres types de traitements qui
sont des traitements qu'on donne en
réanimation et qui dont un était très
célèbre parce qu'il ne fallait vraiment
pas cher c'est qu'il veut toujours pas
cher c'est la dexaméthasone des
corticoïdes mais il ya d'autres
traitements anti inflammatoire qui sont
maintenant sur le marché à la
disposition des réalisateurs et qui
permettent de ne pas de ne pas mourir
quand on est très très très malade ce
que je veux dire c'est que ces mêmes ces
médicaments sont aujourd'hui
insuffisamment utilisée
pour des fins que j'appellerais de santé
publique ce que je veux dire c'est que
aujourd'hui on les réserve parce qu'ils
sont assez coûteux aux formes ou aux
personnes qui ont des déficits
immunitaires et qui ont des très très
fort risque de faire une forme grave si
jamais ils attrapent encore le corps
vidé en plus leurs vaccins marche pas
très bien et sait très bien qu'on leur
réserve semer ses médicaments mais on en
a commandé 40 milles par exemple pour
parler des anticorps monoclonaux en
france on a réussi à en utiliser que
4000 et on s'aperçoit que leur date de
péremption est très bientôt et qu'on va
peut-être perdre beaucoup c'est quand
même dommage de se dire qu'on ne les
utilise pas pour des gens qui sont un
petit peu moins
à risques mais quand même très à risque
par exemple des personnes de plus de 65
ans qui aurait des comorbidités et qui
risqueraient si jamais ils font a causé
des regards d y en a beaucoup en a vingt
mille nouveaux chaque jour de ces gens
qui font des co vide en ce moment on se
dit que parmi ceux là ceux qui ont plus
de 65 ans et compte des facteurs de
risque si on pouvait leur éviter d'aller
à l'hôpital et d'en mourir ben e il vous
remercierai et puis en plus le système
de santé s'en porterait mieux puisque on
encombrerait - les hôpitaux de personnes
qui vont ensuite resté très longtemps
parce que c'est très long
l'hospitalisation donc je crois que il
ya aujourd'hui une sous utilisation de
ses médicaments évidemment encore une
fois c'est pas un reproche que je fais à
personne parce que ils viennent
d'arriver mais il faut que se positionne
rapidement des autorités notamment la
haute autorité de santé pour que ces
médicaments soient prescrits de façon
plus large
parce que même leur coût élevé sera
infiniment moindres que des journées de
réanimation ou bien pire des journées de
couvre feu ou de confinement qui nous
pend donnait comme on le voit dans toute
l'europe en ce moment
jean michel claverie
moi je suis absolument entièrement
d'accord avec le fait qu enfin certains
médicaments antiviraux vont arriver sur
le marché
je suis moins enthousiaste vis-à-vis
encore une fois de la proche purement
immunologique intraveineuse qui elle
aussi va être malheureusement soumises à
des problèmes de l'impossibilité de
jubilé des variants mais il ya quand
même des erreurs stratégiques énormes
qui sont faites par exemple le premier
médicament qui a été avalisé par
l'europe qui vient de chez merck est un
médicament qui a je dirais un
track-record une histoire de dangerosité
extrême puisqu'il s'agit d'un mutagènes
s'éteint c'est un médicament qui fait
causer énormément d'erreurs au virus se
multiplie et donc tellement que ce virus
finit par ne pas pouvoir sont appliquées
parce que ces gènes sont complètement
bousies et qu'ils voulaient
malheureusement ce genre de médicaments
a été très longtemps utilisée dans le
passé enfin essayer dans le passé et on
sait qu'ils ont également une capacité à
jen a généré des variants dans une
population qui serait affectée notamment
par des virus à bas bruit donc je pense
que là encore les erreurs stratégiques
énormes qui sont en fait même par les
pros pagny pharmaceutique at a attaqué
un virus par quelque chose qui est un
mutagènes qui sera d'ailleurs
probablement aussi un cancérogène est
une absurdité je ne comprends pas qu'une
grosse boîte privée comme merck se soit
d'encelade d'or par contre faisait
encore eux ont un médicament qui
marchent pas bien mieux est un anti
protéases donc il n'est pas un agent du
tage haine et je pense qu' il faudrait
effectivement mettre beaucoup des
finances dans l'achat de ce médicament
encore freezer parce que c'est un
médicament qui a très bien marché
notamment dans le cas comme vous savez
du virus du sida
il nous reste quelques minutes le fameux
chiffre de 17 millions de morts qui a
été sorti par six économistes
cette semaine enfin la semaine dernière
plus exactement au lieu des 5 millions
de morts officiels c'est le chiffre
actuel dans le monde
vous y croyez c'est plus du triple
antoine flahault ça vous paraît possible
25 millions mort du co vide oui ça
paraît possible comme vous dites assez
bien c'est à dire qu'
il est clair que les morts rapportées
sont sous-estimés on le sait en russie
où le cern inde on le sait dans beaucoup
de pays probablement même dans nos pays
on a aussi un décalage entre la
mortalité
qui rapportait parce qu'on a fait des
diagnostics parce qu'on a fait des pcr
et puis certaines personnes âgées qui
peuvent mourir avec le cosy d'ailleurs
souvent c'est un peu la goutte d'eau qui
fait déborder le vase il avait d'autres
pathologies sous jacentes
mais ils vont mourir
avec le co vide et ils ne seront pas
recensé parce que on n'a pas fait de
test donc ça je pense que cette
sous-estimation elle est globale l
attaque
s'attache plus à doha certains pays qu'à
d'autres par exemple si tous les pays
sub saharienne pour lequel on a même
simplement pas idée de
l'ampleur potentielle de l'épidémie chez
eux donc je dirais qu will i am alors
comment on redresse ce type
d'incertitude c'est très difficile vous
savez il ya des chiffres qui ont circulé
sur la pandémie de grippe espagnole
encore aujourd'hui les scientifiques
sont très en désaccord sur le chiffre
réel qui a pu avoir c'est très difficile
de faire ces évaluations juste pour vous
dire un tout petit mot c'est la
mortalité par grippe en france je sais
pas si vous savez mais il ya moins de 6
ans certificat de décès chaque année où
on met grippe mais en fait les
statistiques que l'on peut faire sur la
surmortalité liée à la grippe en france
sont de l'ordre de 6000 en moyenne par
an et pas six ans donc il y en a un sur
dix qui seraient rapportés c'est à dire
qu'en fait on fait pas de techno ce type
de grippe la plupart du temps les gens
meurent d'ailleurs il meurt pas
forcément de la grippe c'est un petit
peu ce qu'avait dit monsieur claverie
tout à l'heure c'est à dire que on peut
mourir on peut avoir une autre co
morbidité et que finalement vous allez
avoir la grippe qui va vous faire
basculer et puis vous n'allez pas mourir
tout de suite mais quinze jours après
vous allez décompensé c'est-à-dire
mourir de votre maladie sous jacente et
et cela ce ne sera pas comptabilisée en
général comme une bourse par cris
d'animaux gens méchants travailler oui
ben ce chiffre bien sûr personne ne
connaît vraiment la vérité par contre ce
que je m'étonne c'est qu'on n'arrive pas
à voir notamment en france le
pourcentage réel de la population qui a
été en contact avec le virus soit à
travers effectivement la vaccination
soit à travers en ayant une maladie
extrêmement peu symptomatiques parce que
ça nous aurait vraiment à comprendre
quelle est la part réelle du succès
actuel du vaccin ou versus une unité
naturel et c'est un chiffre qui serait
extrêmement utile pour la santé publique
et qu'on n'a pas il suffit de prendre un
certain nombre de gens au hasard de nos
populations du a rappelé combien ou dans
les anticorps contre ce virus et se
faire une idée
l'état de protection réelle de la
population en incluant le muti la thur
elle est vraiment une partie très
importante et progrès qu'on a fait
actuellement en morbidité et en été sur
le confident france vous remercie tous
les deux d'avoir participé à ce débat
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro des émissions
sur le co vide malheureusement on risque
d'en avoir encore pendant un certain
temps merci et au revoir l'un était à
marseille l'autre à genève je vous
souhaite une bonne soirée
[Musique]